I want to start with a sincere
congratulations I thought this uh I
thought Intergalactic turned out
fantastic oh thanks bro I'm super
excited about it
um as well you absolutely should be um
if some I like throwing a curve at the
beginning uh if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
I would say Blackish
um I think that it was it's you know
something that changed my life and it's
about my family it gives a lot of
context to sort of the types of stories
I like to do and kind of like speaking
about things in a way that's not
necessarily been spoke about before and
yeah I'm super proud of it
I also like black AF
I would probably say black AF I actually
would probably say black AF I think so
the answer got changed I got it I got it
I think that was the version I was a
little bit more comfortable with myself
and it sort of was a little bit more
honest look at my family
okay
um one of the things about an animated
project like this that has so many
different parts is it takes a long time
to obviously make what how long ago did
you start working on this
years
I think it's almost been three years
and has it gone through because a lot of
animated stuff changes dramatically
during the making was this one of these
things where it always stayed the same
where the radical changes
uh yes and no I'm saying I mean we knew
what we wanted to do you know we wanted
we knew we wanted to
you know have it was the first time like
a an album would be associated with a
project in a very unique way in a
proprietary way we knew we wanted to be
about love and romance and you know Guy
meets girl guys this girl guy gets
curled back because that's often not the
stories we get to tell
um we knew we wanted to look different
in a way that we had never seen before
and I feel like very of the moment and
you know and and hopefully of many
moments past this
um I think there was some some different
things of whether it was going to be a
feature whether it was going to be a
series and we kind of found the best
mesh of the two I've read a lot where it
says it's a series but I almost consider
it a movie like what what exactly how
are you quantifying this it's a serious
event
it's a serious event it was broken up by
chapters and
um I think it actually is a really
really good
um good you know analogy for what it is
do you think this could be the beginning
of others like do you envision this
continuing in some way either using the
animation to tell other stories like or
do you think this was like an isolated
thing for you guys uh we would love to
do it as a proof of concept for
something we would like to do for other
artists and maybe either continue this
story or you know do other artists we
think that it's a really interesting way
to sort of introduce
music along with story and to tell you
know
um bring the magic of Animation together
animation especially when you put music
could last forever like my kids are
still singing Moana and Bambi and all
this so the idea of that just can go on
forever yeah one of the other things
that I found really cool is you
collaborated with Virgil for the
costumes and um can you sort of talk
about uh getting to work with Virgil and
um because I think I think one of the
things that's so cool is the way you
melded cool costumes are fat like
everything that's a it's just a cool
Melting Pot well you know Virgil and
Cutty are really good friends I'm a huge
you know Roger and I knew each other but
I was not a friend like Greg Cuddy was
but we knew that we wanted to have in a
way that we hadn't seen from an animated
show we wanted I'm for me as a producer
and filmmaker I always everything in
that screen I think I'm responsible for
from which you hear to which you see to
what people are wearing to everything
and I think that we wanted to make sure
to not lose that because it's animated
and to actually expand upon that and to
get you know virtual ablos
Brilliance in the design aesthetic of
this show and it happens to be you know
one of the last things to use it will do
it's it stands for us as like a you know
it's a a sentiment and uh you know
something that we feel like is a really
special Hallmark of what this project is
I definitely have to ask you I'm so
curious about the white man can't jump
remake I I'm so curious what why is why
is it why is it now like the best time
to reboot it or what can you tell people
about it
um I think that you know that was a very
very special
relationship that started between Woody
and and Wesley right and I think it was
about sort of people from different
worlds coming together and I think right
now that's sort of becomes sort of like
a Hallmark of the stories I want to tell
you know um and it's about you know
people coming from different worlds who
have something that they feel like other
people don't believe in them that they
believe in themselves and it really is
like a perfect time and the soundtrack
Jack Harlow is amazing SIM card is
amazing and the soundtrack you know DJ
Drama is doing our our uh our soundtrack
for it and and it's we think that's
going to be in the same way that you
know we're doing Above the Rim too but
the same way we want to really bring
that back I think music is emotion
motion and we want to bring back big
music to movies and make you feel like
that's a just as part of much of the
movie is as the movie itself last
question for you I'm very excited to see
you people next year uh which I believe
you wrote with Jonah Hill you have Eddie
Murphy in it uh what can you tell people
about it what are you excited for people
to see
um it was my direct feature directorial
debut
um
I was terrified I'm saying we could
spend a lot of money with big stars and
you know seeing your words
that you you know wrote one one is one
thing but seeing the version she wrote
directing them is another
um and I feel like it really does in the
same way take two different takes you
know people have said it's this it's
that it really is talking about two
worlds coming together and the thing
that brings them together is love which
I really not trying to be Sacrament
which I really think the world really
actually needs more of
um I think that people are going to be
Blown Away With Lauren London
um you've never seen Eddie Murphy like
this
um Jonah as a leading man murders it
Julia Louis Dreyfus is you know she's a
surgeon
um David Duchovny who's in it is is
amazing
um Nia Long is amazing we I think we got
like a just a gold mine of cash and I
think people I hope people really
respond to it
um the way that I have been in every
iteration of it really happy with it
cannot wait to see it and seriously
congrats on Intergalactic thank you for
your time thank you bro